let's start today with the latest on the
train derailment in East Palestine Ohio
there's a bunch of different stories
here there's of course the regulatory
story there's the story of what caused
this definitively there's the Pete boot
Edge Story which is building even among
some on the left and saying okay even if
it's not Pete boot Edge's fault
why did he not react or act quickly
after it happened which we will talk
about separately but in the immediate
there's the story about what is going on
with chemicals and risks to People's
Health now I want to start and preface
this by saying this is not a conspiracy
Theory show
we debunk conspiracy theories and when
we talk about what's really going on
with the chemicals in East Palestine
Ohio
we are not even needing to take the
position that there's a conspiracy of
some kind here we just know that there
is a history of wrongly assessing health
risks to people from chemical elements
of different kinds and of being slow to
tell people of that being the case so
when we look at this article from The
New York Times which says many in East
Palestine skeptical of official tests
seek out their own it is not a
conspiracy theory to say
the government whether it's federal or
state
hasn't always been right or honest
initially about these things and so we
want more information the New York Times
says the moves reflect residents
deep-seated mistrust of government
screenings of toxic chemicals and fears
of long-term effects from the train
derailment so this is a crazy situation
that's taking place this is Ohio and
people you can check out the article
people who were not satisfied with what
they were being told about toxic
chemicals have been paying independent
contractors to evaluate what is going on
trying to find tests of their own and
you can read the details and you can
read the names of the different
chemicals and you can read the
statements from Norfolk Southern as well
as the state government but there is a
very long history of this so yes one
part of it is wow people are paying
people are so desperate
to know is what's in the air in the
water are are these things harmful to my
health to my family's health people are
so desperate and they are distrustful of
the government to such degree that
they're going into their own pocket an
area that is not a rich area by any
means and saying we're going to try to
figure out how we can pay to get real
answers here
this is reasonable this is not a
conspiracy when you look back I mean
listen you don't have to think back very
far look at the Flint Water Crisis
that's under a decade ago the city of
Flint Michigan we've talked about this
so many times changed its water source
from uh I believe it was from Lake Huron
Huron I don't even know how you say it
Lake Huron to the Flint River and it was
going to be at the end of the day a
money-saving thing and the river water
was corrosive it caused lead to Leach
from old pipes it contaminated drinking
water
and the latest I saw months ago is that
the people of Flint are still on bottled
water and it took years to resolve it
there were denials there were all sorts
of claims made that everything's fine
and everything was not fine and people
ultimately were indicted
um and then there's so many other cases
in the 1970s there was the Love Canal
Love Canal is a neighborhood of Niagara
Falls New York remember you've got
Canadian Niagara Falls and American
Niagara Falls and residents of Love
Canal discovered that their homes and
properties were built on a toxic waste
dump massive dumps not a satirical term
in this case and those chemicals in the
dump were linked to health problems
birth defects cancer Etc the risk was
initially downplayed by governments and
it took years to eventually evacuate
residents there's all these other
examples we've saw it with agent orange
we saw it with tobacco we see it saw it
with Three Mile Island so it is not a
conspiracy theory to say there is a
record of when these sorts of things
happen governments either out of
ignorance or out of wanting to keep
people calm for lack of a better term
um giving information that is wrong and
whether it's deliberate or not doesn't
really matter when you're talking about
the health of your family so that's
where we are right now
um Joe Biden making a last minute trip
to Ukraine but the uh complaints are the
Biden Administration isn't sending
enough people to Ohio a failed former
president Donald Trump now says that he
will go to Ohio to the site of the
derailment on Wednesday I don't know the
details of that but if it's possible and
if there is a public-facing event
um we will try to cover that and if Joe
Biden goes we will try to cover that as
well but that's where we are and it is
unclear at this point how the residents
of Ohio right now get definitive answers
about Water and Air and soil and and
those sorts of elements eventually I'm
sure we will get the full story
including from official entities but
right now I would be uh skeptical as
well
you don't have to ascribe malicious
intent to it yet but I would also be
skeptical that the full scope of this is
known
Fox News leaked text messages confirm
that while on air people like Sean
Hannity Tucker Carlson and Laura
Ingraham were acting as though there was
Merit and legitimacy to Donald Trump's
bogus claims that he actually won the
2020 election privately Fox hosts were
texting each other and others and saying
this is nonsense we know it's nonsense
this is a really big disaster
fascinating but not altogether
surprising story Rolling Stone has an
article
Tucker Carlson pushes election fraud
BS same night filing reveals he knows
it's BS
Dominion voting systems is suing Fox
News for spreading conspiracy theories
conspiracies about the company's role in
non-existent fraud in the 2020 election
Dominion submitted a bombshell legal
filing Thursday revealing that most of
the Fox News hosts who pushed the big
lie knew it was total BS as well as the
internal strife over how to cover it
these text messages are fascinating
Tucker Carlson was particularly incensed
the filing reveals quote Sydney Powell
is lying by the way I caught her it's
insane he texted to Laura Ingraham on
November 18th
Ingraham responded that Sydney Powell is
quote a complete nut as is Rudy Giuliani
quote it's unbelievably offensive to me
said Carlson our viewers are good people
and they believe it well then why are
you continuing to push that idea
on air he said how did senile hermit Joe
Biden get 15 million more votes than his
boss Rockstar crowd Surfer Barack Obama
results like that would seem to defy the
laws of known physics and qualify
instead as a miracle was the 2020
election a miracle Obama
um so what so the the story here is they
knew it was BS they were texting each
other that it was BS and yet on air they
continued to entertain this stuff as if
it was a serious thing here's an example
of Laura Ingram interviewing Sydney
Powell whom privately she was saying is
a complete nut
to five
point I really need to get after it
right now right now
reports of fraud there are hundreds of
them wow hundreds of report of fraud
reports of fraud that's that's stunning
huh well I hope uh attorney general Barr
is doing that
um very very hopeful that he's doing
that otherwise we're in big trouble as a
country especially with elections going
forward yeah so there's understand
privately Laura Ingram is saying Sydney
Powell is a nut okay publicly Sydney
Powell comes on makes all of these false
claims about the election and Laura
Ingram says if this isn't being
investigated we're in trouble as a
country wow
openly lying to their audience
another example here's actually a good
little compilation that CNN did remember
privately all of these people all of
these people are saying this is nonsense
here's what they were saying publicly
the fix already in it is is a damning
indictment of Fox News the outcome of
our presidential election was seized
from the hands of Voters as a network
publicly and repeatedly promoted former
president Trump's 2020 election fraud
claims to millions of their viewers
every American should be angry you
should be outraged you should be worried
you should be concerned at what has
happened in the election in the lead-up
to this election and privately top
anchors and Executives mocked Trump's
lies calling them ludicrous really crazy
stuff and totally off the rails the
revelations coming from hundreds of
pages of newly released evidence in the
legal filing as part of the Dominion
voting system's lawsuit against Fox News
in this text exchange two weeks after
the election Tucker Carlson texting
other Fox News hosts Sydney Powell is
lying by the way I caught her it's
insane he says about Trump's lawyer
Sydney Powell and Rudy giuliani's
unfounded claims Sydney is a complete
nut no one will work with her ditto with
Rudy Laura Ingram wrote back Tucker
responds it's unbelievably offensive to
me our viewers are good people and they
believe it even as those same hosts went
on the air arguing completely otherwise
all right these election challenges are
still going on and disturbing
irregularities have been found and must
be investigated have they really Laura
made it to the fullest on Election night
the network first to call Arizona for
Biden the Fox News decision desk is
calling Arizona for Joe Biden that is a
big get for the Biden campaign as
Trump's faceless conspiracy theories
started to take hold this is a fraud on
the American public so we'll be going to
the U.S Supreme Court Carl yeah anyway
you guys get the picture so there's a
bunch of different stories here of
course there is again the story
that Fox News lies to its audience for
profit now you could say well but David
all of these for-profit media networks
are going to create content that is
profitable yes but they don't all
brazenly lie while behind the scenes the
anchors are saying we are telling lies
to our audience there is actually a
difference there there are many
criticisms of corporate media that can
be made that apply to all of these
Outlets but this sort of brazen lying
was not being carried out uh by every uh
corporate media Outlet so that's that's
one story The Second Story of course is
that
Fox News presents itself as news
but the people I just named Hannity
Ingram Tucker Carlson when the rubber
meets the road and they end up in court
universally Fox News lawyers say these
are not news people these are
entertainers who use Hyperbole and
exaggeration and that's the argument
they make when they are confronted with
the reality of their lives but there is
a third story here and it's about the
Congressional hearings that are going on
we talked about last week and the week
before the weaponization of government
hearing we talked about the big Tech
hearings Etc part of their story let me
be clear not Fox News part of the story
from the right has been that media was
biased in suppressing news of the fraud
and irregularities the hunter Biden
story criticism of liberals Etc this is
part of the story that they're telling
what those hearings to some degree are
trying to do
is to retrospectively
legitimize and sort of rehabilitate what
networks like Fox News did
to
um uh come down against Twitter for
example for limiting the spread of
certain disinformation rather than
saying hey you know what Fox News hosts
knew they were spreading lies they want
to use the hearings to say forget about
the text messages the Fox News people
and everybody on the right thought they
were telling the truth and it was big
Tech and whoever else that censored that
truth even though privately we know that
they know that they were telling lies so
we will see what the outcome is from
this lawsuit it is a very big deal and
um I will let you know as that happens
but humiliating if you have a sense of
Shame
it's not clear that the Fox News hosts
do there's a very interesting and
disturbing article in Vice that I would
encourage all of you to read about
anti-vaxxers now wanting Revenge
political revenge and legal revenge and
what's extraordinarily disturbing about
this is that it doesn't make any sense
and it's very dangerous and so I'm not
going to tell you everything that is in
this article but the article is written
by Anna Merlin it's part of motherboard
which is like the tech
um side I guess we would say advice and
there's a particular part that I want to
point to here now the subheading of the
article says buoyed by the purported end
of a pandemic that continues to kill
thousands anti-vaccine activists now vow
to punish their enemies these people
said one need to go to prison
there's a particular section of this
article that is very scary okay and it
reads major anti-vaccine figures are now
seizing their chance to enact what they
see as Justice and do a little
fundraising and image burnishing in the
process besides Big Trees non-specific
legal threats we have Children's Health
defense the most moneyed and influential
anti-vaccine organization in the U.S led
by Robert F Kennedy Jr CHD is often
involved in strange and frequently
doomed litigation but recently and with
much fanfare it launched a new one an
antitrust lawsuit against major news
organizations and social media Outlets
which they accused of conspiring to
collectively censor online news about
covid the defendants included frequent
anti-vax targets like the Washington
Post and BBC the plaintiffs are a
veritable who's who of people making
bogus hosts Health claims including CHD
itself Thai and Charlene Bollinger who
run websites and still sell products
devoted to making bogus claims about
cancer and vaccines Jim hoft who founded
right-wing news site Gateway pundit and
Joseph Mercola who I've spoken about
before a long time figure in the Natural
Health World who's been a major funder
of the anti-vaxx movement
um they now are going to try to seek the
Revenge they believe they are entitled
to now it's very important to understand
that the Vindication they are asserting
for themselves they are claiming the
anti-vacs are claiming they have been
Vindicated now
often and I know that this is hard to
believe often it's as simple as oh you
know what we were right they said the
vaccine prevented covid and it doesn't
boom okay
now only if you do no investigation
yourself and completely suspend all
memory of what took place for years
could you believe that in the real world
we have a more evidence-based
understanding not only of vaccines but
of covet and all of these different
things and so for example when you take
the claim they told us the vaccine
prevented covet and it doesn't you have
to remember three plus years has it been
three yeah more than three years of
History the original vaccine meant to
focus in on the original variant was
very good at preventing transmission and
infection meaning with that original
vaccine you were actually very protected
against getting coveted at all
as the virus continued to mutate the
effectiveness of the vaccine against
infection diminished this wasn't hidden
there was no cover-up it was all over
the news as soon as it became uh known
and over time the vaccine became less
effective down to most recently from the
latest studies I've seen essentially not
effective at all at preventing infection
or transmission the vaccine became
primarily a tool that will prevent you
from getting a sick and prevent you from
dying with relatively good efficacy
arguably saving Millions if not more
lives
that doesn't vindicate the anti-vaxx
people the anti-vaxx people were saying
the same thing all along what changed
are the circumstances of the virus and
the vaccines similarly they claimed to
be Vindicated over side effects
myocarditis pericarditis except they'll
never tell you the real data about the
risks of those conditions from the
vaccine versus the risks of those
conditions from covid that's something
they conveniently leave out they insist
that there were cover-ups about
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin and
zinc and vitamin C and vitamin D and all
these different things and they say they
won't even allow it to be studied but
you can look up and find endless
peer-reviewed studies about all elements
of that it seems as though maintaining a
good level of vitamin D generally
speaking is a good thing for fighting
off a lot of infections and that
includes covid that includes covet the
zinc uh zpac vitamin C thing does not
appear to be useful Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine have now been studied
very much uh extensively not effective
on covid so the Vindication they claim
one could only believe if you either
aren't paying attention or aren't
actually looking for scientific
peer-reviewed data but that doesn't mean
they aren't going to ruin a lot of
people's lives with these lawsuits and
these calls for Retribution so read the
the vice article we'll link to it in the
description to the YouTube video for
this story and we'll talk more about it
as those lawsuits move forward
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
2024 Republican presidential candidate
Nikki Haley is really struggling she has
now had a week to try to figure out an
answer to what are the policy
differences between you and Donald Trump
and she is still unable or refusing to
cite any differences now I think this is
more about strategy and the possibility
that Nikki Haley is actually running to
be Trump's Vice Presidential nominee
than it is about her inability to
actually come up with differences
between what she would do and what
Donald Trump would do but it's starting
to get a little bit embarrassing so
we're going to look at a clip from Fox
News Sunday during which Nikki Haley was
interviewed by Fox host Shannon bream
now you might remember that last week
Nikki Haley was asked multiple times on
days two and three of her campaign what
are the differences between you and
Donald Trump
and she basically made it about identity
she's younger was the long and short of
what she said refusing to really
criticize Donald Trump and what you have
to understand is that this is very
similar in some sense to what we started
to see in 2015 and 2016 which is it's a
version of ignoring Trump now it's a
different version in 2015 2016 many of
the Republican candidates ignored Trump
because they didn't want to take him
seriously and they assumed if we ignore
him he will go away and yet what Trump
did was he won by attrition as one
candidate would drop out he would pick
up the vast majority of their two or
three percent and then that would get
him to seven eight and and then they
would keep ignoring him and then someone
else would drop out and then he would
pick up their one or two percent and
that would get him to 9 10 and you
understand this is a different version
of ignoring Trump which is we don't like
Trump we know about the anti-maga people
in the Republican party that's who we're
targeting but
we're also not going to really put a
Line in the Sand and draw any kind of
Distinction from Trump so will it work I
don't think so but I don't know that
it's designed to work if you're Nikki
Haley and you're running for VP this is
arguably exactly what you have to do but
it is pathetic take a look at this she
says she's focused on Joe Biden the
problem is she's not going to get a
chance to face Joe Biden unless she wins
the Republican nomination clearly you
think you're a better option than he is
or you wouldn't have gotten into the
race so where do you two differ
I don't focus on President Trump and
it's amazing that the media wants to
talk about that so much well it's not
really amazing there are two candidates
you and Trump so if you're going to talk
about this race at all
17 months out or whatever the natural
thing would be you compare and contrast
the two candidates she won't allow that
because she will draw no distinction
from Trump other than his age and his
gender we'll have to because after the
GOP Primary you will have to focus on
him and Governor santis or anybody else
who gets in to get to president Trump
you will have to get through that field
my announcement was to a few thousand
people in South Carolina I just had
packed rooms in New Hampshire not one
person asked me about President Trump
everybody wanted to talk about Biden
everybody wanted to talk about the
problems facing American families I am
focused on Joe Biden he's the one that's
the president you know I will tell you I
think Americans need to have options I
think they need a new generation I think
we need new energy going in I think we
need to leave the status quo of the past
and start looking ahead and that's what
I'm going to do and as much as people
want to talk about other opponents
they're it's shut she acts almost like
it makes no sense that one would talk
about the opponents in the race she's
running she's running in the Republican
primary so naturally you would talk
about her opponents right now there's
one his name's Donald Trump we'll be
more
remember last week Donald Trump is my
friend listen there's two possible well
the two part there's two reasonable
possibilities here that explain this
other than she's clueless one is she's
not running for for president she's
running for VP and so the way to get in
Trump's good graces is to do as well as
she can in the primary without attacking
Donald Trump that's one possibility the
second possibility is she's counting on
Trump getting indicted and having to
drop out and by not attacking Trump
maybe she will end up being seen the
most favorably by the Maga people such
that if Trump ends up indicted and
dropping out she will they will switch
to supporting her these are gambles I
have no that whether it can work is
predictive in nature and it really
depends on whether those things happen
um she also hears like a bonus clip
during the same interview
she sort of couldn't explain why she was
running which is really just a fail
um check this out this is she she's
asked like why would someone vote for
you and she's like why not okay so I
want to put up something for the Wall
Street Journal this week they said you
had a a great day your great rollout day
but they said you have to provide a
rationale for your candidacy that you
haven't done yet they said you've got to
answer this question about why you
versus anybody else in the uh in the GOP
field you know they're talking about the
fact that you say you know America First
America should be powerful those are
things that any GOP candidate is going
to say so why you
why not me you know I am a the wife of a
combat veteran I'm a mother of two
children one who's getting married and I
see how hard it is for her to look at
buying a home are these credentials in
Nikki Haley's mind to say make her the
president it's in college and I see what
he's dealing with with woke education
you know
her kid is dealing with woke education
so it follows logically that you would
vote for Nikki Haley huh a daughter of
immigrant parents who are upset by
what's happening at the border that's
identity politics of course I don't want
to wait for someone else to fix this I
want to make sure we get in there and
fix this I'm not a lawyer I'm an
accountant I've never worked in DC and I
think it's time that we start putting a
fire under what's happening in Congress
I think we need term limits I think we
need mental competency tests for for
people over the age of 75 and I think we
need far more transparency than we're
seeing today and what I do strongly
believe is the American people need
options I don't think you have to be 80
years old to be in Washington D.C this
is like getting sad this is really
getting said why should anybody vote for
you well why not and it's good to have
an option that is under 80 years old
whoa pretty compelling stuff I really
like the vision of America that Nikki
Haley is laying out here and I think
it's time for us to start getting
aggressive getting back to what it means
to end socialism in this country
[Laughter]
what
when did socialism start in this country
that would be my question to Nikki Haley
um this is really sad and pathetic and
you know the the most positive spin you
can put on this is that this is a play
on
if Trump's indicted she'll just be there
or she'll be Trump's VP but this is a
campaign that is going nowhere very very
quickly and uh we're going to continue
following it and seeing if Nikki Haley
is interested in putting together any
kind of coherent explanation as to why
she's running all right let's go now
from Nikki Haley who is officially
running in 2024 to Ron DeSantis who is
not officially running in 2024. this is
super interesting
um Fox News interviewed Ron DeSantis
this morning
and said hey what do you think about all
of these Republicans that are attacking
you now the main Republican who has been
attacking Ron DeSantis is Donald Trump
no mention of it on Fox News just they
they don't even mention it
what exactly is going on here I have an
idea and I will tell you in a moment but
let's take a look at this clip and again
when you see how every day Trump is
attacking DeSantis how do you interview
DeSantis about all of the people that
are attacking him and not mentioned the
main guy who's doing it look at this
you've come under a lot of incoming fire
recently uh Nikki Haley taking aim at
you Larry Hogan as well the governor of
Illinois uh you know from your visit
coming up here to Chicago
what's your reaction to some of those
attacks
okay so it's already weird because like
who's paying attention to Larry Hogan's
attacks everybody's paying attention to
Trump's attacks well Lisa you know if
you're in if you're an office holder and
you're just sitting there twiddling your
thumbs and not getting anything done no
one ever says anything you can kind of
just fly over under the radar but when
you're out there leading when you're out
there setting the agenda not just for
Florida but really for the nation which
we've done he's setting the agenda for
the nation this does sound like a guy
who's running over the last few years uh
people see that and and the people that
don't necessarily like that are going to
respond accordingly but I can just tell
you uh if people are not firing at me
then I must not be doing my job and so I
view it really as positive feedback well
listen you could get some positive
feedback if you just stood up turned
around and said hey folks I'm going to
run for president just saying you would
wind up with the standing ovation right
now we'll give you 20 seconds you guys
like to have have that announcement
so listen
um we we are going to delve into this in
a lot of different ways but what is Fox
News doing here how does Fox News which
has been softly leaning towards DeSantis
and softly getting ready to get away
from Trump if Trump is not the nominee
why don't they bring up that the Lions
share of those attacks have been coming
from Donald Trump that that's who people
are paying attention to and we'll have
examples of it later on in today's show
not Larry Hogan and Nikki Haley nobody
really cares about those attacks on
DeSantis well it seems that it's part of
the same strategy we've seen which is
Fox would rather someone other than
Trump but if it is Trump they don't want
to openly be hostile to him now Trump
has already started targeting Fox to
some degree talking about syncing
ratings and different things things but
it seems part of that same strategy Fox
isn't ready to abandon Trump yet but
they do want to set themselves up to be
friendly with whoever and so the the way
is you bring on to santis you ask him
about the attacks on him you just don't
mention that Trump is one of the people
that's been attacking him they're
creating
fake it's the the there's constantly an
elephant in the room that people aren't
mentioning and this is the latest
example of it it's going to be a wild
primary that's for sure all of the clips
I played for you in this segment you can
find on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show and on
our Instagram
just search David packman show on
Instagram
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show
Republicans plan to force candidates who
want to debate in the 2024 primary to
sign a loyalty pledge clearly here
geared at getting Donald Trump to say he
will support whoever the eventual
nominee is going to be and this is the
latest in an ill-conceived and
potentially completely self-destructive
idea from the Republican National
Committee I will explain why let's talk
about these loyalty pledges the
Associated Press reports Republican
primary candidates will be blocked from
the debate stage this summer
if they do not sign a pledge to support
the gop's ultimate Presidential nominee
according to draft language set to be
adopted when the RNC meets next week the
proposal sets up a potential clash with
former president Trump who has raised
the possibility of leaving the
Republican party and launching an
independent candidacy if he doesn't win
the nomination while RNC officials in
Trump aides downplay that possibility
such a move could destroy the Republican
party's White House aspirations in 2024
and raise existential questions about
the party's future
this is so potentially disastrous for
the Republican party and I love it now
interestingly a senior Trump aide could
not say whether Trump would sign the
pledge to support the eventual nominee
but suggested privately that he plans to
participate in the debates campaign
spokesman Stephen Chung declined to
answer the question directly as well
Chung said president Trump is the
Undisputed leader of the Republican
party and will be the nominee there is
nobody who can outmatch president
Trump's energy or the enthusiasm he
received from Americans of all
backgrounds so listen
um I don't think Trump can do this I
don't think Trump can sign that loyalty
pledge and there's a couple different
reasons why
first of all existentially
uh Trump may not win the nomination we
just don't know yet if you put him head
to head up against DeSantis it's not
that good if you put him in a multi-way
race he has a plurality but that could
change and what if he gets indicted or
whatever the case may be there's all
these different scenarios so Trump in
order to maintain leverage and power
really can't sign this pledge because he
kneecaps his own power part of the power
of trump right now
is that if he chooses to go and run
third party
he ends Republican chances in 2024. the
math of it is relatively simple we've
talked about it before you think about
all of these states which are swing
States or their Republican states by but
only by a few points if you take a state
that Republicans usually win by three
Trump saying I'm running third party
if he pulls even just 10 or 12 percent
of the vote in those States it'll mostly
come off of the Republican nominee and
the Democrat ends up winning Trump
running third party is a gift to
Democrats if it happens I would love to
see it he would he would have the chance
at being one of the most successful
third party candidates in history I mean
in the modern era
um you've got Ross Perot is the one that
mostly comes to mind
um Trump would really have a shot at
being one of the more successful third
party candidates in the modern era and
it would destroy Republicans possibility
of winning so that would be absolutely
fantastic but there's another sort of
aspect to this
which is
much of Trump's campaign
like in 2016 is going to be based on
attacking his fellow Republicans and
making fun of them and talking about how
terrible they are and all these
different things
how can Trump seriously attack Ron
DeSantis in the way he's been attacking
him
if he has also signed on to support
DeSantis no matter what if DeSantis is
the nominee it fundamentally doesn't
work and so the Loyalty pledge actually
risks pushing Trump towards that third
party run in the following way if
Republicans if the Republican Party
really holds firm and says Trump if you
don't sign this thing you can't debate
by the way not allowing a former
president to debate would be
unbelievable and many people are writing
to me saying David they would just
Buckle they would just say oh no no
you're allowed to debate but imagine
that the Republican Party says you've
got to sign this loyalty pledge in order
to debate Trump doesn't sign it they say
we're not letting you debate
that pushes Trump to go and say you
won't let me debate I'm no longer
running in your primary I'm now running
third party that's it Democrat wins in
2024. so Trump really does have a very
powerful tool in his pocket and he can
use it like a cudgel he genuinely can
it'll be fascinating to see if it
happens the Trump DeSantis Feud has
exploded as Donald Trump spent the
entire weekend posting to truth social
truth essential attacks on Ron DeSantis
including going full Rhino Trump giving
Ron DeSantis the full Rhino treatment
remember that Rhino means Republican in
name only it's a pejorative attached to
Republicans that someone feels aren't
really Republican so let's take a look
at Trump's posts he is not holding back
despite claiming he doesn't even think
about Ron DeSantis he spent the entire
weekend posting about him Trump first
posting quote in writer Selena Zito's
fake news puff piece about DeSantis
which supposedly appeared in the dying
New York Post which is way down in
readership just like Fox News is way
down in ratings why doesn't she mention
that he wants to cut Social Security and
Medicare loves losers like Jeb Bush Paul
Ryan and Karl Rove
and it getting clobbered in the polls by
me DeSantis is a rhino who is trying to
hide his past I don't read the New York
Post anymore it has become fake news
just like Fox and The Wall Street
Journal anyone who doesn't suck up to
Trump and pray at the altar of the uh
great failed former president is now a
rhino and his fake news and is bad
but understand that this is a dramatic
escalation Trump last week said I don't
even think about Ron DeSantis and then
he spent the entire weekend trothing
about Ron DeSantis Trump continuing
Trump content and by the way isn't Trump
really the Rhino and what I mean by that
is Trump never represented Republican
values Trump wasn't even really a
republican that we knew of for the vast
majority of his life until he started
getting traction by criticizing Barack
Obama
um if there's any real Rhino it's
actually Trump but let's put that aside
for a second Trump continuing to post
quote Ron de sanctimonious wants to cut
your Social Security and Medicare closed
up Florida and its beaches loves rhinos
Paul Ryan Jeb Bush and Karl Rove
disasters all is backed by globalists
club for no growth Lincoln pervert
project and uninspired Coke
and it only gets worse from there he is
a rhino in Disguise whose poll numbers
are dropping Like a Rock Good Luck run
you know for a guy who says I don't
think about Ron DeSantis he will not
stop posting about Ron DeSantis and
seems completely consumed by Ron
DeSantis and that's how you know Trump
is lying when he says I don't ever think
about this thing and anybody who says I
do is wrong and bad and evil in line
it's a signal that that's exactly what
he's spending his time thinking about
and it's clear that he is and then
another one this morning Trump just out
of control truth Central quote support
for DeSantis cools in latest GOP poll
Washington Times of course it cools he
wants to cut Social Security and
Medicare loves throw them off the cliff
Paul Ryan who is destroying Fox News In
The Wall Street Journal piglet Carl Rove
and quote Jeb also Ronda sanctimonious
is for globalist club for no growth and
open borders Charles Koch we want
America First not America last that's
the ranting of a Madman there's no
denying it there's no way around it but
I said I don't know if all of these guys
and gals really have what it takes to
face Trump in a national campaign in
which Trump ignores all rules of decorum
the very same ignoring of all the rules
of decorum that made the us a joke
internationally When Donald Trump was
President are the rules of decorum that
generate media attention and that get
those folks who aren't that close
followers of politics but they like a
good fight and an interesting combative
personality it brings them out of the
woodwork and that's why Trump won in
2016. it was missing from 2020. that
part of why Trump lost 2020 aside from
failing on covet uh is that he didn't
have the environment that he had in 2016
to do this sort of stuff this really is
Trump in his element that's the crazy
thing and so I know not everybody in the
audience agrees with me on this
I think unless someone can match Trump
on this sort of stuff
um he has a very good shot at running
away with the 2024 nomination let me
know what you think leave a comment
leave a comment let me know what you
think and uh look forward to hearing
from you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community
see when we're taking calls live and
stay up to date on other Big Show
announcements WE Post daily find us on
Reddit Twitter Instagram Facebook
Discord and tick tock
let's talk today about virtue signaling
and its cousin dog whistling I get so
many emails about this and it really is
a good opportunity to talk about it this
is these are both terms that are often
used you may have heard this term being
used to criticize people on the left for
their activism or their uh organizing
their efforts virtue signaling the left
are virtue signalers what does that
actually mean and by the way it is
really the right that participates in a
lot of this virtue signaling which I
don't think will come as a surprise to
you at this point virtue signaling means
when you express a moral or an ethical
stance or a political stance it can even
be
in order to gain approval from others
and Signal your virtue virtue signaling
means I express an opinion which I may
or may not really hold which I may or
may not really even understand in order
to signal to others that I am saying the
right things so that they then will have
a better opinion of me
it can take many forms it could be you
post things to social media about your
charitable donations or your activism in
order to Signal your virtue you publicly
Express outrage over some issue in order
to appear socially conscious or that
you're on board or whatever the case may
be now it's really important to
understand that engaging in activism and
expressing values is not inherently bad
that that's not the point of virtue
signaling as a pejorative when the
signals when the actions are being done
when the signals are being sent
primarily to gain social approval or
status that's when it becomes virtue
signaling rather than simply expressing
an opinion the right loves to say
that it is the left that predominantly
engages in virtue signaling but much
like the right likes to say the cancel
culture is on the left when the cancer
culture is actually on the right as
we've talked about before much like the
right likes to say
that it is the left that is engaging in
voter fraud but in fact it's mostly
happening on the right it is exactly the
same with virtue signaling let's talk
about how the right engages in virtue
signaling conservatives might display
American flags or say I support the
military in order to signal that they
are patriotic and to gain approval from
their peers in many cases they don't
really care about either but they are
using those symbols to support the troop
stickers whatever to signal that they
are on the right team when it comes to
those issues or they might say we've got
to stop this cancel culture from the
left the left we I'm for free speech
because they want to appear to be
defending values that are currently in
Vogue even though they neither care nor
understand what the hell they're talking
about nor whose speech is being limited
blue lives matter stickers or
paraphernalia or whatever to show we
support law enforcement in the military
they might not even really care or
understand what's going on with law
enforcement or the military when they
use phrases like I support Traditional
Values I am about real America
you're talking about signaling that you
support conservative cultural norms now
we're slowly starting to get over to dog
whistles which I will get to in a moment
other examples of right-wing virtue
signaling include
um posting on social media about how you
want border security we have to have a
border when you live in you know Iowa
doesn't mean you can't care about
immigration when you live in Iowa but
for many of these folks it is a form of
virtue signaling sometimes expressing
religious beliefs or even going to
church to be seen at church can all be
examples of right-wing virtue signaling
but and this is where we start getting
into dog whistles virtue signaling and
dog whistles are two different things
when we talk about dog whistles we're
talking about coded language or symbols
that have a hidden meaning
that is meant to communicate a
particular message to a specific
audience often there is bigotry or
Prejudice in dog whistle so I'll give
you some examples different ones are dog
whistles to different degrees when
people have been talking about I support
medical Freedom during the pandemic
often what they mean is I'm against
vaccines and so it's a dog whistle more
than a virtue signal in that it is coded
if you're not part of the discussion you
would your medical freedom I don't know
it sounds good yeah sure why not but it
is often a dog whistle for anti-vaccine
um talking about often the word Urban
particularly talking about like gun
violence needs to be dealt with for what
it is an urban problem they're talking
about black people okay so Urban in
certain contexts is a ver is a dog
whistle for black and or brown people
um sometimes Law and Order can be a dog
whistle where you're sort of saying well
I'm tough on crime but Law and Order is
also often used as a dog whistle to
support uh racially biased policies like
for example stop and frisk
um America First is sometimes a dog
whistle to White nationalists and others
states rights is one that's been used by
politicians to support
policies that discriminate against
minorities roll back civil rights states
rights has been used as a dog whistle up
to and including support of slavery
quite literally when they talk about the
Civil War
globalist can be a dog whistle for Jews
we've talked about that one extensively
before so both virtue signaling and dog
whistling involve sending a message to a
particular audience the difference is
the virtue signaling is more about
gaining approval whereas the dog
whistling is more about communicating a
hidden message to those who understand
the terms so both important terms to
understand
when I use them in the future hopefully
they will now be more clear let me know
what you think of my missing examples of
either that are relevant check this out
Marjorie Taylor green tried to make a
statement about how not racist she is
and in doing so she made a horribly
racist comment I'm gonna play this for
you it is some really really wild stuff
and uh I'll just play it for you and
then we'll talk about it I know a ton of
white people that are as lazy and sorry
and and probably worse than black people
I know
Marjorie Taylor green
to prove to us how not racist she is
says you know what I'm not racist lots
of white people are even as or lazier
than black people I know that might be
hard to believe if if you can believe
this
there are also lazy white people who
challenge black people for laziness did
that just come out wrong Marjorie or am
I misunderstanding what it is that you
were saying
um there's actually a uh a longer clip
um that I'm trying to find let me see if
I can find it here which gives a little
more more context
lazier I think would be the key word
here
uh
uh no I'm not able to find okay so uh
it it did this is really a a disgusting
person really a disgusting person and
during this same this was during like a
live that she did of some kind answering
questions I don't know
she said on the issue of Confederate
statues black people should actually be
proud of Confederate statues because
it's a reminder of how far the country
has come this is crazy I don't want our
statues taken down in our country I
don't think you remove or erase history
so I do I do agree those statues
shouldn't be taken down right they're
part of our history we should learn from
our history we don't erase it but that
doesn't make me a racist because I
because I say leave the statue up there
if I were black people today and I
walked by one of those statues I would
be so proud because I'd say look how far
I have come in this country look how far
my people have what they have overcome
and these are good things yeah it's just
like you know in Germany if they had
Hitler statues obviously we would all
say these are great reminders of how far
we've come we used to have Hitler here
and now we've come so far and so the
more Hitler statues you have the better
reminder it is of how far we've come
what an imbecilic thing to say now I
have gone back and forth over the last
you know couple years that Marjorie
Taylor Green's been around
as to whether she's really this dumb or
whether this is sort of a character
she's playing
this live thing really gives me the
impression that she's genuinely this
dumb I don't I don't think this is a
character that she's playing
um let me know what you think but I have
a very hard time believing that this is
a staged in any sense of the word we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here's a comment about my
coverage of George Anthony devolder
Santos and specifically how I have sort
of taken a light touch when it comes to
his previous marriage to a woman
um in particular I've said there's a
long history of gay men who aren't
living as gay men publicly marrying
women
also the marriage to that particular
woman might have been an immigration
scam but anyway this caller says there's
something else I'm doing wrong in my
commentary take a listen to this
um have one little complaint about your
coverage of George Santos please uh you
talked about LGBT members and gay gay
men who are potentially married to women
uh to heterosexuality but you've
completely forgotten the fact that
bisexuals exist and are attracted to
both I would appreciate if in the future
you keep that in mind and don't erase
the b in the LGBT community I am not
erasing bisexuality in my coverage of
George Anthony devolder Santos he has
never asserted that he is bisexual if
that it I would just be Crow barring
that in for no we have no reason to even
consider that in the sense that Santos
has had every opportunity to talk about
his sexuality and he's never asserted
that so it's not about he's either I
mean I guess if you could take the
approach that if he's lying about his
his sexual orientation the truth could
be anything and that conclude bisexual
but I don't know why we would suspect
that in particular uh other than
um the the story of the immigration scam
which quite frankly seems like the most
plausible one to me at this time so I
would never erase bisexuality but uh I
also don't know why I would necessarily
insert it either we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about Senator Rick Scott
dropping his plan to cut Social Security
and Medicare despite the fact that he
spent the last two weeks claiming that
that plan didn't exist
but now he's dropping it but it also
didn't exist very complicated we also
are going to talk about one of the
greatest culinary lies in the history of
the United States the boneless chicken
wing the boneless chicken wing it
doesn't exist there is no such thing
there's no Wing in a boneless wing we're
talking about a piece of the chicken
breast or the tenderloin and we are
finally going to get to the bottom of
this culinary lie and also Ron DeSantis
is now looking to expand the death
penalty in Florida what does this mean
how is the Catholic Church reacting to
it a really interesting story about
Rhonda Santos that's not getting nearly
the attention it deserves so we will
talk about all of those stories and more
when I am joined on the bonus show by
producer Pat oh the bonus show where you
want to make money yeah everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad let's make that cash right Alex on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a discount I will
see you then
foreign